Alright, so we know we need to change fifths and tenths into tenths. So to
change fifths into tenths I need to multiply by 2 over 2. And then for 3 10ths
it's already tenths. So I don't need to change it. So let's see what happens
when I change 2 5ths into tenths. I know if I multiply my fractions I'll get 4
10ths. Here is what that would look like, this would be 4 10ths of a kilometer.
Remember I doubled the number of pieces that I had, I went from 5 pieces to 10
and I doubled the number of pieces thatI had. I had 2 5ths originally And now I
have 2 times 2, which is 4 or 4 10ths. Visually we can see that 2 5ths of 1
kilometer bar is the same as 4 10ths of 1 kilometer bar. They really represent
the same length. My 3 10ths of a kilometer doesn't change, I'm just adding it to
the 4 10ths.